migrants believe there's an open border
I don't think the more than 1.5 million
people who have been removed or expelled
from the border would consider the
Border open but political leaders
communicate that the border is open that
is music to The Smuggler's ears and the
Smugglers themselves
absolutely you're not going to say that
the administration and the policies on
remain in Mexico are title 42 or
stopping construction of the wall that
that had no impact Chris that's not what
I said when you say it's what does
secure mean to you it certainly doesn't
mean that people aren't able to get
across the border illegally of of course
not that is that by that measure the
board has never been secure so by what
measure is it secure now sir so there
there is not a common definition of that
like of course he was trying to blame
the Republicans for everything and when
the Republicans were securing the border
and building a wall and doing all those
things they said it was racist